Clara et Angélique ont 16 ans elles ont
commencé à travailler à 15 ans en pleine
pandémie
en même temps je pouvais me faire de
l'argent elle jongle avec l'école et le
travail j'ai eu des petits problèmes au
début parce que je travaille plus autour
des 16 heures et mes parents voulaient
pas trop c'est un peu compliqué et j'ai
un homme à dire non dire non à son
employeur n'est pas facile compte tenu
de la pénurie de main d'oeuvre c'est
donc pour protéger les jeunes de plus en
plus nombreux sur le marché du travail
que Québec veut légiférer a provoqué une
augmentation aussi
considérable du nombre d'accidents de
travail entre 2020 et 2021 la CNE SST a
noté que les accidents de travail chez
les moins de 16 ans ont bondit de 149 à
203 une hausse de 36%. il faut également
prévenir le décrochage scolaire et on a
réalisé qu'au-delà de 15 16 17 18 ans il
y a un risque de décrochage qui est plus
important
Québec recommanderait l'interdiction de
travailler avant 14 ans sauf exception
entre 14 et 16 ans le nombre d'heures de
travail serait restreint 17 heures par
semaine pendant l'année scolaire dont
Deezer maximum du lundi au vendredi les
associations patronales salut le geste
où la priorité et l'éducation ça ne
vient pas exclure les jeunes du marché
du travail au contraire ça vient
simplement encadrer le contexte dans
lequel ces jeunes vont pouvoir avoir
accès au marché du travail pour elle qui
travaille auprès des jeunes le projet de
loi est une excellente base mais il ne
suffira pas à lui seul à discipliner les
employeurs je des lois qui existent sur
le travail des enfants mais souvent les
employeurs soit ne la connaissent pas
très bien ou ne l'applique pas loin
c'est important effectivement mais il
faut bien la faire connaître la faire
reconnaître pour que les employeurs
respectent les limites des jeunes
comment angélique et Clara qui ont bien
l'intention de réussir leurs études tout
en travaillant
ici Marie-Josée paquet de Comores au
Canada Montréal